ان نتابع واياكم هذه الصور التي تصلنا ل
همم لحظه وفاه اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيليه بيليه طبعا وكالات الانباء
بدات بعرض كل تفاصيل مراحل حياته واهم
محطاته الكرويه في العالم الرياضيه اذا
وكالات الانباء تورد الان خبر وفاه اسطوره
كره القدم البرازيليه همم وهذه الصور من
محطاته طبعا هناك الكثير همم يعني
المعلومات المهمه عن تاريخها كمحترف سابق
ويعتبر احد اعظم اللاعبين في كل العصور
يصنفه الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم بالاعظم
وكان من بين اكثر الشخصيات طبعا نجاحا
وشعبيه في هذه اللعبه في القرن ال 20 في
عام 99 تم تسميته برياضي القرن من قبل
اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه وتم توجه ايضا
في قائمه التاينز الاهم لمئه شخصيه في
القرن ال 20 لاهم 100 شخصيه في القرن
العشرين تم التصويت على بيليه ايضا اذكى
افضل لاعب في العالم من قبل الاتحاد
الدولي لتاريخ واحصاء كره القدم وكان احد
الفائزين
بالمشتركين بجائزه لاعب القرن من فيفا تم
الاعتراف له بالف ومئتين 279 هدفا في
1363 مباراه بما في ذلك المباريات الوديه
كارقام قياسيه في موسوعه جينيس اديسون
تو وهو بيليه الذي يتوفى اليوم التاسع
والعشرين من ديسمبر من عام 2022 عن عمر
نهز 82 عاما وقد ولد في الثالث والعشرين
من اكتوبر من عام 1940
يتوفى بعدما سجل نفسه اسطوره في تاريخ
المهاجمين الرياضيين العالميين وهو اييي
البرازيلي الجوهره السوداء تتنحى تترجى
اليوم عن عالم الرياضه
وابنته تقول الان نحبك بلا حدود ارقد
بسلام ابنه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
تقول على انستقرام الان نحبك بلا حدود
وارقد بسلام